the rel
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones video
as you all know game of thrones and a
song of ice and fire
are full of mysteries there are so many
things about this world we still don't
know
even after eight seasons of the show
there were still so many loose
ends for example most of us have
wondered
why did the white walkers decide to come
back now why do the winters
and summers last for so long what did
varys hear in the flames
where is helen reed what is the faceless
men's
ultimate agenda did the mad king really
hear
voices in his head what would we find in
valyria
or in the shadow lands beyond asshai
these are only some of the mysteries
that have millions of fans scratching
their head
out of all the different mysteries in
game of thrones and a song of ice and
fire
there is one thing you can find on
everyone's list
this is arguably the single greatest
mystery
ever known to man we all want to know
what podrick did to the woman
working in littlefinger's establishment
what did he do
that allowed him to get this kind of
service for free
now for those of you who don't remember
let me go back over those scenes so you
know exactly what i'm referring to
before this character ever won his first
gold medal during the bedroom gymnastics
he was mostly known as tyrion lannister
squire
while he was working for tyrion he
showed just how good of a friend he
[Music]
more loyal is
not only did he remain loyal when he was
on trial for joffrey's murder but he
also saved tyrion's life during the
battle of blackwater bay
you could say he was there for tyrion
when he needed him the most
when no one else really was for that
alone he deserved a reward
so after talking it over with braun
tyrion decided to give him a feast for
bros
inside littlefinger's establishment the
day podrick walked in there he was a
virgin
however when he walked out he was now
known as a man
among boys a god among men not only did
he allegedly satisfy those women
but they also refused to take his money
it's as if he gave them something they
had never experienced before
this is where the mystery lies how was
he able to get these services for free
we all know littlefinger does not like
bad investments remember roz
do you remember what happened to her
i hate bad investments
really i do
they haunt me
i don't think he would be very happy if
he knew his workers were giving money
back
unless littlefinger himself made sure
that happened
now there are a lot of theories
surrounding this magical event
i could make the video super serious but
i would rather have some fun instead
now speaking of ross she said podrick
isn't necessarily a very large man
well not any larger than all the other
men they typically see
is he very large no larger than usual
apparently and yet they said that he was
extraordinary the most extraordinary man
they've ever had
and they've had a lot of men we're
talking about the same podrick
quiet boy it sounds like this may be a
case of
it's not the size of the ship it's the
motion in the ocean
as i was saying before there are so many
different ways you can look at this
when you consider he had no experience
before this most would assume he
finished rather quickly
now if that was in fact what happened
why would they give the money back
did they not want his money because
things ended so fast
i don't want to believe they felt sorry
for him besides
it doesn't sound like things ended fast
anyway because tyrion makes note of how
long he was gone
tell me todd
have you ever been with a woman oh my
lord
wonderful jenna
specializes in first time
ah the return of the conquering hero
does he have a little jump in his step
well that's practically skipping you
were gone a long time
i trust you got your money's worth or
should i say my money's worth
oh it was a gift podrick it sounded as
if he were with those ladies for several
hours
mayhaps he knows how to work well with
his hands or mayhaps he showed them
what that mouth do as you all know there
are other ways to get the job done
if i were a betting man i would say he
used everything at his disposal
i mean there were three or four of them
and only one of him after all
not to mention when he spoke to tyrion
right after he was done
he did say they did lots of things it
doesn't sound like they just sat around
having a conversation
now you could say maybe he lied this
certainly would not be the first time a
man lied about his bedroom activities
maybe it's just me but he doesn't seem
like the kind of man who would lie about
a thing like this
there are also those who would say maybe
tyrion gave the woman the money in
advance
as a way to boost his confidence this
also could have been a way for tyrion to
see if podrick would give the money back
we have seen him challenge characters in
other ways before
although i don't think this is likely
either i don't think he would need to do
this right after podrick just saved his
life on the field of battle
this is game of thrones though so you
never really know
now according to the actor he said he
believes podrick was most likely just
very nice
and accommodating to the woman working
in littlefinger's establishment
he said the women most likely dealt with
men who weren't very nice at all
who may have also been selfish so to
meet someone who was the complete
opposite
must have been an amazing experience now
some of you may or may not know this but
those scenes are not in the books
chances are dan and dave wrote these
scenes as a joke
we aren't supposed to be thinking about
it this much but let's be real here for
a second
we are game of thrones and a song of ice
and fire fans
overthinking and over analyzing
everything is what we do
in my opinion i like to think he really
did give them the greatest experience of
their life
even if ross was right when she said he
wasn't an above average man
based on everything else we have seen
and heard he did not need to be
he was able to satisfy them in other
ways for several hours
regardless of whatever those other ways
were at the end of the day
i think he got the job done let me know
what you think happened
do you believe he really is a god among
men do you think tyrion gave them the
money in advance
do you think the woman lied was
littlefinger behind
everything like he is with everything
else
leave me your thoughts down below i
can't wait to see what you have to say
as always i have to thank everyone for
watching my video i hope you all have a
great day
i will see you again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you